just got back from a five-hour flight
three-hour delay y'all want a video
because I've been slacking on the [ __ ]
so I came back was gonna sleep last
[ __ ] y'all deserve what you gonna get
and it's a video oh I'm here hey what's
going on YouTube guess I just have my
last and final short in Oregon so I'm
back from that tour and grind did you
miss me I think you did I do my they all
now in your group of friends we all know
about this one guy the one guy in your
group that is always [ __ ] angry I'm
not talking about myself I may be angry
all these videos I'm not happy all the
time
look at this nah mostly you just lost a
lot of respect for me but you know the
guy or girl that I'm talking about is
the dude that always gotta cause a
[ __ ] scene and ruin the move for
everybody because he or she is always
angry
selfish and you guys ever noticed that
when it comes to these type of people
the reason why they're angry is always
over nothing got a mosquito bite I
didn't go H it I go inches it's good
mother what here's the thing when you
get angry and upset yeah it's completely
understandable you are allowed to feel
how you feel because it is your [ __ ]
that's poetry for those of you who don't
know Shakespeare 1882 ad 46 prehistoric
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if y'all know somebody
like this it's time to put them in check
so you already know what it is else
y'all baby let's get a mess down calm
down you angry piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] why
must you always make everyone feel so
uncomfortable
I'm so [ __ ] upset I'm doing the
Italian hence you look about him about
our you unsocialized [ __ ] if you had an
ounce of intelligence when you are that
angry you would realize that you are
making everybody feel uncomfortable
because by the time you are done yelling
and cursing and [ __ ] ruining the mood
do you realize that nobody's left around
you
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
with your sample do whatever the hell I
want and another thing [ __ ] you
to put no sprinkles on my [ __ ]
ice cream if I have a captive and
sometimes it's not even the fact that
you're mad that bothers people it's how
long you let it drag on when you get mad
at somebody who pisses you off on the
spot I think it's perfectly fine as long
as you don't carry it with you for the
rest of the day you say a quick buck
release it and then you're good to go
what the [ __ ] y'all want to go eat you
see that you said the [ __ ]
release the anger but after that it's
all good I'll do it all time watch this
Shh I'm hungry you get every for a few
seconds your mood passes and the
conversation goes on but these people
who get mad and they let it carry on for
a very long time they have to tell you
why they're angry over and over and over
shut the [ __ ] up
you're angry we get it we heard it for
the first 30 or 40 [ __ ] minutes if you
don't shut the [ __ ] up we're gonna go
buy a bazooka fill it with a bag full of
nails explode it in your butt wrinkled
of a [ __ ] face don't be mad cuz
nobody loved you do you know what you
need you need a hug
is it Chekhov I don't know whack
yourself off like a grid like a if you
know for a fact that you were gonna
socialize and be around a group of
people stay at home if you're gonna be
that pissed off why don't you just try
jacking off real quick
you can't even get mad after you jack
off trust me I tried back back down I
mean right you know what I don't pretty
blacks actually you guys never noticed
you about half the time that they're
angry usually it's their fault so not
only are you met when you get wrong when
you [ __ ] up you live even more mad at
yourself what the [ __ ] whoa what's wrong
dude my [ __ ] part is felt like [ __ ] I
don't know until our cool it's your fart
now I know what you're thinking you
would think that the angry guy in the
group is me but you're wrong I have
solved much like these titties come here
titty [ __ ] would eat me I'm not really
angry I'm what you call the height man
i'ma do when you been to a fight I got
your [ __ ] back at home in my bed
watching Netflix mmm baby you down [ __ ]
down down 12 o'clock tonight
hello hello this [ __ ] I'm not a really
good fighter cuz I can gang fights I
personally wouldn't know what to bring
the last gang fight I got into I brought
water balloons [ __ ] I'm right
here
well what'd you break down bacteria
warfare I'd figure [ __ ] put in my
butthole stick it in your eye you won't
get pinkeye you don't know but it's
gonna [ __ ] you up in like two weeks
well I bought a gun so there's gonna be
easy it's like back what blue is are
serious weapons you don't know this LA
tap water it got um chlorine and River
River flat sides that's it that's a word
hey what is going on YouTube yes I am
back I hope you guys liked that new
intro that I have I started switching
things up on the David so comedy channel
and guess what people funny fat fit
we'll be back in action starting this
Wednesday because now tours over and now
it's time to get rid of a and B and
maybe you know make my C get a lot
bigger but yes funny fat fit we'll be
back on Sunday and yes you like we'll
have another video on Sunday coming up I
got more sketches coming out for you
specifically one with Danny TL ha ha see
y'all next Wednesday and Sunday catch me
there
peace out don't touch babies and stick
your dick some possums cuz I've done it
before [ __ ] was really weird
mmm-hmm Merkin number